There is nothing more humbling than when you run into a younger family member
that you haven't seen in a while,
younger your relatives that are either married or have kids
you're always like wow,
you've grown up so much,
because in your head they stayed that same age as when you last saw them,
and they ask you like oh
what's new with you?
and the only thing you can think of is
I celebrated my cat's third birthday
made them a tuna cake and gave them catnip
oh and last week I organized my pantry!
that was so much fun!
But for the most part,
I don't leave my house unless it's out of a necessity..
so..
It’s truly humbling experience, when you run into younger relatives